how do I start a business with zero
experience if you don't have any
experience in the field that you're
trying to get into then it's so
important that you go out and get some
experience there's so many reasons why
it's important but first of all imagine
you're selling something to your clients
that you're not very good at doing right
does that make sense you think you're
going to have a lot of success when you
don't really know what you're doing
probably not right if you if you've
never started a business before you
don't understand how entrepreneurship
works then your chances of success are
going to drop dramatically and this is
important because I want you to have the
highest chance of success possible most
businesses will fail and a lot of times
is because entrepreneurs start up and
they're not great at what they do they
don't have any experience I think it's
going to be easy and they end up
crashing and burning to give yourself
the highest chance of success you need
to get experience since a couple ways to
do it I want to answer this in frame of
a question that came in from one of my
youtube viewers love you guys Ivanka
wrote in to say he needs my advice on
how to start up a business I have a
dream of owning a web development
company I'm not skilled I have no
capital I've just started developing
recently I have a huge passion for it
please can you give me some advice this
is a great start okay if you are
passionate about your business your
chances of success go up dramatically if
you do not love your business if you're
not passionate about it insanely
passionate about it you're dead in the
water you're not going to make it you're
not going to have an impact you're not
going to make money stop now and start
something that you are excited about
that you believe strongly in but from
there Yvonne has just started out okay
this is you if you have just started out
you've discovered your passion you want
to build something but you have zero
experience you have to go get some
experience okay there's two main ways to
do it number one is go get a job and
number two is start working with clients
even if it's for free just to build up
your portfolio and for you to get
better your eventual goal is to dominate
your industry it's become master class
at what you do is to become one of the
best in the world at what you do
specifically okay and to do that you
have to work on projects and I would
actually suggest combining the two
options together get a job and start
working with clients for the get a job
part go find the company that you look
up to I'm not saying just go get any job
okay that's not going to help you get a
job to learn you get a job to understand
how business works while getting paid to
do it it's like going to university but
being paid to do it and being paid to
make your mistakes you're making
mistakes on somebody else's dime so if
you want to start a web development
company go find a small web development
company small I mean like maybe ten
employees where you can go and look up
to the entrepreneur who started it you
can get involved you can learn your
trade better you can work on some real
projects you can try to get as close to
the entrepreneur founder as possible to
learn about how to start this kind of
business and they'll do a number of
things for you it'll tell you one do you
like this industry you know you thought
you did but now that you're in it you
actually like doing it or not - it'll
give you training on how to be a good
developer so you need to get better at
your development skills this is your
opportunity you're going to learn from
people who have done it and three it
will teach you how to be an entrepreneur
right because running a successful
business is going to be more than just
developing a great product you're going
to have to understand all the basics
around launching the company servicing
clients sales and marketing
administration everything that you need
to do to run a successful business and
you'll learn it again while you're
getting paid to do it and you're going
to make mistakes while getting paid to
do it so you're increasing your skill
level
I don't you're just going to get any
other job okay you have to be really
focused and targeted on the kind of job
you take and understand that it's not a
long-term thing you're there to learn
you're there to learn quickly and when
you're ready you can go launch your
business now at the same time I want you
to start learning how to work with
clients okay start building up your
portfolio start building up your
expertise start
taking on projects even is for free
because you're you're working here to
learn right now you're working here to
build up your skills and then once you
can become master class then you're able
to charge and not just charge a little
bit you're charging a premium because
you're so good at what you do and to get
there you have to work on real projects
so start taking on clients for free just
to build up your experience just about
the portfolio and as you get better you
can start charging and charging more and
charging more and eventually you'll be
so confident in your skills and your
clients will love you so much
that you'll be able to leave your job
and focus on your business full-time
this gives you the highest chance of
success it's so important because a lot
of people start a business they think
it's easy they run out of money three
months in and think I'm never going to
be a successful entrepreneur go back and
get a job and they live with regrets for
the rest of their life and I don't want
that to be you I don't want you to look
back 20 years to say I wish I did this
differently so give yourself the best
chance of success learn the business get
a job in the field learn from the
entrepreneur build up your skills start
taking on some projects from outside
clients get to the point of survival
where you know that you can make enough
money from your business to put food on
the table pay your bills and just
survive and from there you have the
launching platform to build a successful
monumental business most entrepreneurs
can't get to survival they can't get to
the point where they have enough money
just to support themselves which is why
they quit so give yourself the best
chance go get the job learn from people
who have done it and I'm excited to see
this business of yours grow
I know it's hard I know you want to do
it quickly entrepreneurs we don't have
patience and that's a good thing you
know you want to be out there hustling
and you want things to happen now and
quickly and use that force to drive you
forward and make something great happen
because it is within your reach if you
give yourself the best chance of success
believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below it
always makes you want to do more for you
and I'd love to hear what you have to
think let me know what you think about
this video leave a comment underneath if
you have a question ask it below I will
make a video response for you thank you
so much and I'll see you soon